welcome to this video playing he would
youwould 45 I have played him two times
and 12 times that's good news but all
serious about to end sometime okay I'll
play night h3 against the stone what if
possible this has a good reputation I
don't know it too well but it is some
power it is so often played as white as
I getting the chance yeah okay should I
just take be aid this is sometimes
played just take rb8
but it does not feel right to me really
be should be five maybe yeah if 97 oh
it's not to operate okay just just take
them and no neither form maybe to get it
into play before I place a g5 the armor
black seems to be okay maybe queen bee
three years right I know sometimes this
is played in um in the slide but
probably not exactly here now he gets in
a quick g5 also yeah
if I go 95 people take it and if i take
with the f point you will play a form
which is not nice now maybe take it with
the depot okay it's not even taking
wherefore was interesting okay but now I
get in a for myself
yeah as I think I should be okay Liam
it's not not anything for white in terms
of an advantage but it's still fairly
solid now let's do that before you take
that good could happen okay I probably
just have to have to trade things off
him check
yeah but if I go Queen Queen g3 you're
never going to to njm or queen g to them
let's do Quinn g3
yeah I doubt that you can can activate
the rope here the moment it sets of
course a direct mate yeah so not
possible at all but I really doubt that
is that it is possible at all let's see
want to go with g2 and roop chi 2 and
King edge too
yeah but you're not really doing
anything here Queen g5
yeah trading off to a king and porn end
game is probably not a good idea at
least it shouldn't do it that it would
lead to anything okay I can just keep
the Queen's on him check
check hmm I don't know what he's doing
here is he tried to lose this game I
mean some he can play it down much
simpler I think
Jim I really don't know what what is
trying to do him Wow
since then I don't tell you don't really
get it sorry I don't get it at all check
go here Queen d3 check and then go to
edge for and then I'm just winning with
white I'm or not
check I mean maybe here yes has some
some sort of draw but
maybe queen of three years I can take
bullying pawns time morning I can I can
even play Kingi 5pm King g5 and go to h
6 h-6 I play King g6 check mmm isn't
this winning Queen g5 I can also take
your first but Quincy five looks like
check it should win check
ya can't cone end game with an extra
pawn that looks looks quite tasty check
check check check check should there
should have been something better only
check check probably a Miss play chess
end game check check check check oh we
can trade now wow this was stupid ah
unbeliever hmm check stalemate wow this
is for this area you should get the
idiot of the day price Wow not winning
this is quite remarkable what is exactly
wrong with all this I should play f5
what of course I must play this because
this is this is of course winning yeah
and then this now gets very easy yeah
how so stupid can you be and this is
really only in leading to this this
Queen endgame you had the screen and
Camus is a win but how to do it in
nineteen channels chatchai actual under
the day possible to flee quickly check
yeah this is a relatively easy win if
you have the time but with two points
they are almost all winning
even with one pawn most key and porn
queen and poor night games are winning
but it was of course totally unnecessary
22 to do that and he plate plate plate
luckier buzzer was playing for la CM can
also check here I mean this is not so
very simple maybe this is the easiest
actress that we look at this briefly
check check here now this is probably a
maid somehow check something like this
check yeah this is this is Chet leading
to checkmate it was very very difficult
to not win the game but I managed okay
thanks for watching